la plataforma mesa de la unidad
democrática que agrupa a los partidos de
oposición dijo este martes que tomaron
la decisión mayoritaria de participar en
las elecciones de alcaldes y
gobernadores del próximo 21 de noviembre
después de un extenso y difícil proceso
de deliberación interna y su
participación es noticia porque la
oposición ha dejado de participar en los
últimos procesos electorales por
considerar que no hay garantías
electorales además de que un importante
número de políticos fueron inhabilitados
en las tarjetas de partidos ilegalizados
y precisamente esto es lo que demanda la
oposición en la mesa de negociaciones en
méjico condiciones electorales para
dirimir el conflicto político en
comicios presidenciales en el texto la
oposición dice que sabe que las
elecciones no serán justas ni
convencionales pero que será un terreno
de lucha útil para impulsar unas
elecciones presidenciales libres hay que
aclarar que este anuncio de la
plataforma política mesa la unidad
democrática y no del llamado gobierno
interino liderado por juan guaidó